[موسيقى]
اسرتنا
دق دق دق دق يا دق دق بصحبه ماما راحت
ماما ستبتع له الحلو وسياره بمقودها
[موسيقى]
بصحبتي
ماما ستبدا له الحلوى وسياره بمقودها
[موسيقى]
لكن دقدق باك شقي
قد ازعج كلب الحرفي
طارده من قلب المنجر واحتاج لعوض فوري دق
دق دق دق يا دبدوق دق دق يا دبدوب سحب
كذلك سله بيض
فتناثر سقط على الارض
قالت ماما ما تفسده لاصلحه احتاج للمرض
دندق دق دق يا دقدق دق دق دق يا دمدوق بص
سياره بالمقودها دق دق دق دق يا دقدق
ذهبان محل الالعاب بردت يجري دقدور كسر من
العجله دونك وتحطم ايضا صندوق دفعت ماما
لتعوضه
لم يبقى لها ما تنفقه
قالت هيا نذهب دندق لكن هذا لم يعجبه دق
دق دق دق يا دقدق دق دق دق يا دقدق وبكى
دق
دق العباد
قالت ماما لن نجلبها
لا نملك مالا يكفيها بشقاوتك لن تملكها
بشقاوتك للتملكها
عاد الى البيت من السوق يشعر بالندم
لافعاله اينا سياره والبوق اين السياره
والبوق
[موسيقى]